[Music]
nick
is with us in greenville south carolina
hi nick welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well four years ago i got stupid it's
all chapter 13.
uh moved in with my sister she kicked me
out in july
so i came home once no ain't no big deal
man the dog jumped in the truck
well i made the last payment on that
chapter 13 today and
then can i tell them they can have this
truck
you made the last payment on the chapter
13 today you're living in your truck
what kind of truck you talking about a
semi yes sir
okay so you're driving over the road yes
sir
and i'm so tired of this okay now i do
have the va so
you know i don't really need like the
down payment or anything
i'm just curious you know i know it's
not gonna i don't know
is was the truck did you have it
financed in the 13
oh no sir no sir i'm a company driver
i'm not an owner operator oh it's not
your truck
no sir okay all right so you're just
you're just you and the dog are living
over the road
and you're sick of the road and you
finally got your 13 closed up
so all your bills are behind you yes sir
i mean i'm debt-free you chipped i just
don't have a house yeah so what are you
going to do for a living if you come off
the road
i don't know if i may i may go back to
running city or
find something completely different okay
cool what do you make now
about 60. do you have any debt at all
um no sir okay do you have any money
um after today no okay i don't think you
got two hundred dollars
you're done and you're done so you're
gonna be driving a little while longer
agreed
yes sir yeah i mean i'm not trying to
jump out of it today i mean i'm just
looking realistically
how long am i looking at because 20
years is too long i got you
i got you we need a better plan this
this one doesn't this one doesn't scale
well
i got you and i and i agree with you by
the way how old are you
22 cool you're obviously single
yes sir okay all right what i would do
is rent
before you buy i wouldn't worry about
buying today
because with the chapter 13 it's just
obviously messed up your credit you file
bankruptcy
um and yeah you can get in on the va and
there'll be more lenient on that
but i wouldn't today um instead i
if i were in your shoes i would say all
right if i drive
x number of months let's just pick out
you pick out a number and i you
what let's call it six months i'm gonna
drive for six more months and i'm gonna
pile up
uh ten thousand dollars okay
okay i'm just making this up whatever
the numbers work out you you decide if
it's eight months fine if it's five
months fine i don't care
and if it's not ten thousand dollars if
it's eight thousand dollars that's fine
but you need a little nest egg
between you and life because life's been
kicking your teeth in for a while okay
okay a little pad like ten thousand
dollars would make you walk a little
more
a little strut a little more rather than
walk right
yes sir okay uh and then i would just
get me an inexpensive
one bedroom apartment rental get me an
inexpensive
two thousand dollar car that i pay cash
for and i would line up a job that gets
me off the road
i'm sorry my pickup was my pickup was
included in the check
13 and that's paid off oh good so you
got a car i don't even have that
okay yes sir what's it worth uh
16 ford f-150 i had an offer for 16-6
i think okay all right
that's a lot of car for where you are
right now if you want to hold on to it
you can i don't care you got it paid off
uh or you can sell it today and have
fifteen thousand dollars in cash in your
pocket right
right that'd be tempting to me and get
me a 5 000
truck um and have 10 000 in my pocket
and go ahead and start looking for a job
to come off the road and looking for a
little one bedroom apartment to come off
the road
and get your life set because your
rhythm right now is throwing gears
that's your whole rhythm and i want to
reset your rhythm
into not being out of town you and the
dog have an apartment
uh or a little small home of some kind
something it doesn't have to be much
because you're not going to be there
forever you're going to be there for two
years while you finish
this transition out of the 13 and off
the road
does that make any sense yes sir
and nick there's some there's some
literature out there there's some
nerd research out there that talks about
what it's like to sleep in your own bed
for 60 days
for 90 days and your whole body your
whole mind starts healing itself
and there's something about showering in
your own place and sleeping in your own
place
and suddenly things clear up when it
comes to thinking right and then this
new job this dude what am i gonna do
next some of those things get a little
more clear because you get a little more
stable and a little deeper sleep
if i were you i'd start looking for a
job today as soon as i found one i'd
sell my truck get me a five thousand
dollar truck and come off the road
and if you can do that no we gotta do it
and i got i got hey i got fond memories
of just me and my old hound dog in a one
bedroom apartment for a couple
it was awesome man no doubt
right and just kind of you know and then
just kind of get
you know off the road no bankruptcy no
crap flying around your head
and you you get a calmer more
uh more calmer more peaceful rhythm to
your life
and then that allows you to start
growing your career into the future
that allows you to start you know
plugging into a good church
that allows you to start working out
again that allows you to
uh you know think about buying a home
two years from now and start setting
some goals on all of that
and um if you were my little brother
that's what i tell you to do
if you want to keep the truck and wait
four months or five months and pile up
some cash that's fine
i would personally you know i think
you'll get you know the truck someday
soon
and i'd i would rather personally be off
the road and get this fresh start if i
were you than on the truck but that's
just me
you get to decide that as to how quick
you want to do that but uh to me that
is an unusually large item value-wise
in this story it stands out
in this story and so i would use it to
reset my life
and get in a slower peaceful rhythm
that i can use to build my wealth build
my body build my spirit
build relationships again because you're
just you're just gone all the time
you're throwing gears man
and when you don't when you're sleeping
in a truck you're not all the way asleep
you're not sleeping for seven eight
hours at a time you're not
getting that you don't have that place
to anchor into yeah
yeah and it sounds like there's some
relationship steps you need to work on
well let's go back and call on your
sister and slowly start to heal that or
heal in some of those old relationships
man but having a good place that you
anchor in so that you're steady and
you're having that just
peace man yeah um then that's a great
place
great news is you're free from the
bankruptcy it's all in your rearview
mirror so you get it you got a
whiteboard you got a brand new day
brand new year brand new thing yeah as
soon as you can find a job if i'm you
i'm gonna sell the truck and come off
the road yeah and i start looking today
that's that's you do whatever you want
but that's our advice for you listening
to you
and i really really appreciate the kind
of guy you
are that you're you're a guy that just
scratches and scraps
pushes through makes it happen me and
the dog jump in the truck and got her
done
yeah you know 60 grand crush doing a
great job man you're working your butt
off
going all the time i love that and i
just i think the next phase is going to
be so much better for you
you got some real cool things in the
next 12 to 24 months for you
if you make real careful wise choices